alright we are live welcome to another
Google+ Hangout I'm really excited today
today I'm with Corey McDermott and he's
got a podcast on leadership and he wrote
out he wrote to me and said hey I want
to interview you for my podcast and said
why don't we turn into a google hangout
so my audience can learn about core and
everything that he's up to so Corey's
got his usual intro and everything so
I'm going to forward it on the him and
kick this thing off boy so thank you so
much Evan for agreeing to to the
interview and the way that I always
start my shells is just like this
welcome leaders i'm your host coin
mcdermott and today i have Evan
Carmichael with me his first business
started at the age of five selling
drawings door to door with his younger
sister at the age of 19 he built and
scored a biotech company and at the age
of 22 helped a venture capitalist go
from 500,000 250 million dollars Evan
now runs Evan Carmichael calm a website
for entrepreneurs ending to help 1
billion entrepreneurs change the world
so Evan I've given the leaders a quick
snapshot about you but in the next few
minutes can you tell us and describe
yourself all right um you did your
homework there hahaha I believe it
entrepreneur so I had a business I I
mean you talked about some of the
history there after I sold my first
company I was asked to do a lot of
speaking and help entrepreneurs I was
his young entrepreneur kind of success
story I was 20 22 sold my business and
that was something that I just I fell in
love with helping you know I almost I
almost failed I almost quit I was making
three hundred dollars a month with my
company and and I just told my partner I
quit and I could have been one of those
statistics of the eighty percent plus of
entrepreneurs that fail and as a result
decided to use the knowledge and
experience that I gained to help other
entrepreneurs you know not fail like I
almost did and that's been my driving
passion for the past I what is it like
12 years now that 12 years well time
flies and so
do it through my website through
interviews through my radio show through
my youtube channel through speaking
working on the book deal lots of
different kind of app renews I'm
basically working on ways to help
entrepreneurs believe in themselves and
build companies that they can be proud
of amazing amazing so before I even go
into the next question just want to
quickly tell your audience i apologize i
had the youtube video actually open
listening to myself as an echo so if you
saw some weird faces sorry about that
back to the interviews though of what
what is one trait Evan that's that you
have that you would consider makes you
an effective leader um a good question
uh I think to be an effective leader you
have to like people you know um you have
to lead people and so you have to like
people and actually care about them and
I have a we're diving deep on the site
psychology now against but you know I I
like pleasing people I like I like
people to be happy and sometimes I hurts
me as a leader to our guests but um I
find that I you know I actually care
about all the people in my company like
truly care right I want to make sure
that they're happy that they are not
just happening what they're doing at my
company but happy as a person and happy
in their life and I think that that
shines through you know I have a lot of
loyalty from my team and they do things
kind of way outside what's expected
because they they want to because they
care about me just as much as I care
about them and I guess that sounds
fluffy but it's true like I actually
care about the people on my team I want
them to be successful sometimes that
means like they shouldn't be on my team
anymore because their interests lie
somewhere else and I can't provide that
opportunity for them but I think you
know that may be really high level and
really simple but actually caring about
people and wanting your team to be happy
and successful I think is the foundation
for any successful leader I could not
agree with you more and I know that you
said that it sounded fluffy and here's a
great way to make it not sound as fluffy
where it is can you tell us a story of
how you used that trait of caring for
people to build success um sure and
maybe I'll give you a couple so what
does one guy who worked for me who um I
found out that his passion was baking
and and he was doing marketing for me
and and he was having okie result but I
could tell like he wasn't it wasn't he
wasn't as invested into it like I was
like everybody else and the team was and
and he was kind of just your average
employee and and I don't you know we
don't do average and and I had a chat
with him and and then they got giving
him time to go off and explore baking
and ended up leaving my business and he
became super grateful for that uh and so
you have a part of that is sometimes
people aren't a right fit for your
business and by actually caring about
them like he was a guy who was
performing he was doing this job there
were no issues there was no reason to
fire him and as a business owner you
know losing somebody means I gotta train
somebody new I gotta do the whole search
process a lot of time and investment
that I put into him and and it was the
best thing for him and and he's super
happy now and and you know continues to
talk about me in the business in a
positive way so that's an example of
when you know I had to let somebody go
because it was in their best interest um
another example I guess have one that's
on the positive side uh you know I had a
I have a my team as remote for the most
part and that's a whole other discussion
it might be interesting for the chat but
I had a person who works for me in the
Philippines and he he was a fantastic
worker the great great job and then this
huge typhoon or flood hit and Annie went
offline for a while and I didn't know
what had happened and what
was going on and um his his wife had
some serious had some serious condition
that happened as a result of the flood
and I funded the medical expenses for it
because he didn't have enough money to
cover because they lost everything in
the flood and that is you know she was
overwhelmingly grateful and happy
obviously and he was and it just takes
it takes the commitment to a whole new
level like they already enjoyed the work
they were doing they already enjoyed
helping entrepreneurs you know they
enjoyed the tasks enjoyed the team but
now it's like and it wasn't even a no
break it wasn't even like oh I should do
this because I think he's going to be
loyal to me and he's going to give extra
work it was just like can I help like I
actually care about you can I help you
with this and so that's maybe an extreme
example but that kind of stuff happens
all the time you know when you have
discussions with people on your team and
you asking about what they're doing you
know on a personal level you find ways
to either just understand what they're
going through always that you might be
able to help them those were two great
stories Evan thank you so much for
sharing so on this journey to becoming
an entrepreneur and really on any
journey but especially on a journey
becoming an entrepreneur you're gonna
have a lot of people who doubt you and a
lot of people who tell you that you
can't do something so how do you
challenge yourself to overcome naysayers
this is a huge huge topic I love it I
call those people the little man no man
is a person who tries to bring your
ideas down who often never does anything
of significance themselves they they
just bring other people down and and I
like to think of it as you know if you
have a new courageous idea you're like a
gladiator in the ring you know you're
you're fighting you're out there trying
to live your dreams you're not going to
win every fight but you're trying like
you you get up when you're trying to do
something different and and the little
man is a person in the audience is just
throwing popcorn at you when yelling at
you and telling you your bum but they're
they're never going to be a gladiator
like there
always going to be up in the stands
heckling and yelling and so that's uh
that's what I think about the little man
and we all have the little man in our
lives we all have these haters these
naysayers who try to bring us down who
will poke holes in you know when you're
first starting a business when you're
first on a new idea you don't have all
the answers right you don't have it
you're you you just came up with this
great idea you're working away on it and
there's gonna be a lot of holes on it
and and your friends are going to be the
people who who find the holes in your
plan and say hey here's here's some
holes here's how you can fix it here
sings to think about where the little
man is a guy who's just you know
pointing at all the holes and and say
it's not because of this not going work
because of that and I know I don't have
all the answers yet I'm trying to figure
it out that's why I'm asking the
questions uh and so I think what a lot
of people go through is they they a lot
of people have a fear to be bold and and
their environment holds them back and
what ends up happening this is so common
people want to start a business you wake
up at two in the morning because you had
this great dream and this great ideas
again this is my idea i'm gonna i want
to start a business is this is what it's
going to look like and then all the all
the doubts you know start to creep in
you know you go back to sleep the next
to you wake up is I don't know I can i
do that i don't think i can do that that
was what was i think i was such a stupid
idea and you know you have that moment
of boldness and then it goes away you
wake up the next day it's all gone and
part of what you need to do is create an
environment that then brings you up that
builds up your confidence that builds up
your motivation that makes you believe
in yourself because you are a product
not only of your five friends but your
product of the environment you're part
of your routine your product of the the
TV shows you watch and the newspapers
you read and the podcast that you
subscribe and listen to right so you
want to design an environment that makes
you think bigger that makes you believe
in yourself that makes you want to go
that next step that make you think yeah
I can't accomplish that because the
friends and the fam
and the things that you're consuming
your life are holding you where you are
and if you want to do something bigger
then you've got to step outside that
comfort zone Wow uh I don't dream dream
is really what I want to take out of
that dream and make sure that you are
creating an environment to help foster
your dreams and to help foster the the
idea to keep dreaming and this goes
right into the to my next question for
you perfectly what is one routine that
you have in the morning that you
attribute to your daily success yeah the
morning routine is so important i think
if you set a morning routine for
yourself and you're like whether you're
an entrepreneur or you know whatever
you're doing um the reason why it's so
important is because you will have
moments of inspiration okay you will
have a maybe you listen to this podcast
you know you listen to cory's podcast
and maybe you listen to it at you know
four o'clock in the afternoon and you
get inspired well that was a great
interview I'm gonna go out and you know
reach my goals you know now I believe
myself but you wait until four o'clock
that day right and the next thing you
got to start all over so why don't you
start your day with things that get you
excited and motivated so that you have
the entire day to set up your set
yourself up for success and so um I have
a pretty strict morning routine that I I
typically follow that gets me set up for
success and it usually looks like this
I'll wake up and I'll I'll I'll send a
message to my wife she wakes up a lot
earlier than I did when is off she has a
nine-to-five job well 1995 really but
she has a regular working job and and
I'll message her just like a little hard
or a happy face or something and i'll
also write down next to me three things
that I'm grateful for for that day and
and sometimes it's uh you know deep and
profound like I'm talking about my wife
or my family or or you know my son or
might be something random like I'm
grateful for the internet you know I'm
grateful for the Sun I'm grateful for
you know my bed yeah I don't know
whatever comes to my
but I find that by starting your day
with with love and gratitude it just it
just opens you up like you know it just
sets you up for a mindset of being open
to want to go out and do something to
help people um and maybe that's fluffy
too but I find it helps it works for me
the next story on turn on some music
music is the fastest way to instantly
change your state and I have a belief
playlist my i'm all about believe i've
got the shirt on and i have a playlist
that gets me excited it gets me moving
and you should put your favorite songs
on you know whatever whatever song makes
you start dancing and bobbing your head
and moving like the song comes on you
want to get up and you want to move
right we all have those favorite songs
so make a playlist and put that on in
the morning because as soon as you're
moving and active then again you're
building that that exciting thing
yourself to go out and do something um
then I look at my I have a big wine and
a little why and the big why is you know
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs I
want to reach a billion entrepreneurs
with my message why am I doing this
that's that's that's my big goal and so
you should have a big goal that
motivates you to get you excited that
makes you want to go out and conquer the
day and remind yourself of what that is
and doesn't take long I look at it a
billion entrepreneurs I kind of look at
it and not just read it but try to
embody that for a couple minutes and
then I look at my little wise the
challenge that you'll face is sometimes
that big goal motivates you and
sometimes that big bold looks too big
too far off too I can't accomplish that
Who am I to help abelian entrepreneurs
you know little man you can be your own
little man kind of seeps in and so the
little wise are the everyday occurrences
that help you move closer to your goal
so for me the big wise a billion
entrepreneur is the little why are the
individual entrepreneurs that I've
helped and so one of my favorite parts
of the morning is going to my youtube
channel and respond in the comments as
people are leaving comments on my videos
to say Evan love that video thank you
some
I change my life it's really helped my
thinking uh and that gets me excited
right like I'm having an impact on
people and so I want to go do more of it
and so you need to find your own little
wise unfortunate now that I have enough
of a following on social media and
Newser and all that that I get that
feedback loop constantly but when I was
her starting I didn't have that right I
didn't have a popular youtube channel i
didn't have a popular twitter channel or
people on my news out of list what i
would do is i would make a powerpoint
file and look at it every morning just
with comments of people that i've helped
whether it was a friend and i helped out
or whether i spoke at an event and
somebody left a great remark and i'll
just remind myself that hey you know the
work that i'm doing is meaningful to
some people even though i'm not seeing
huge results yet even though like i'm
struggling and i can't get this thing
off the ground yet I've touched a few
people's lives the stuff I'm doing is
meaningful not even close to my billion
goal but I'm having an impact and so
remind yourself of the people that you
have touched the people that you have
helped and so I find that that whole
routines are starting with gratitude and
love and then going to music and then
remember my big why and remember my
little wide and also having lemon water
every day I'm always surrounded by lemon
water because you're dehydrated in the
morning you got out some water to get
you excited but that's it that's my
routine and it works and and it helps
you get excited every morning instead of
waiting to be inspired by somebody else
or some random meeting or something that
happens in the afternoon or night there
you have it leaders lemon water a spirit
of gratitude your big y and your little
why I so helping a billion entrepreneurs
that's that's a large goal what do you
do to relieve stress relief stress um
that's a good question how much do I get
stressed i think i think the billion
entrepreneur goal isn't stressful for me
it's not something that I stressed out
about
it's something that I think is
achievable and that excites me I think
when I get stressed out mostly it's uh
when I'm either bad stress and I'm doing
work that I shouldn't be doing work that
I don't enjoy doing work that is either
not my skill set or just work that I'm
not passionate about and at times we all
have we all have these things that we're
not passionate about but we have to do
and so I relieve that stress by by
delegating it eliminating it automating
it like get it out of my life right and
that goes for negative things and you
know you know- friends- people- TV shows
or media you know something is making
you stressed or negative get it out of
your life look you don't need that in
your life surround yourself with things
that make you excited so you know I've
structured my business so that I am
doing for the most part things that I
enjoy doing I'm talking to you because I
enjoy I enjoyed your email i draw your
message though I enjoy what you staying
for so I figured hey this is going to be
a great call um then I think the other
stresses is is good stress in that
you're doing things that stretch your
comfort zone doing things that help me
move closer to my billion goal but maybe
I've never done before and I'm I'm
nervous about an out there you know I
live in my bubble we all live in our own
bubble and you got it slowly like expand
that bubble to build beyond what you're
comfortable doing and so that kind of
stress so here's an example even today I
secretly hope that before going into a
call the person's gonna cancel on me cuz
I like I don't I still get nervous going
into a call a meeting you know like we
had a little technical issues like oh
maybe okay okay both are canceled great
move on to some you know but it's fine
like I love talking to you this is what
I always have this like secret little
because i like to please people uh I
guess my own internal fears that i won't
i won't do a good job i won't you know
your audience won't be happy you won't
be happy i'll make whatever um and so I
secretly kind of hope that you're gonna
cancel on me for some reason but that
that hurts my
you know my bigger my bigger goal so
like that's that's good stress like I
should be doing that I need to be
stretching my comfort zone I need to be
busting through that and I think you
know what helps with that stress uh it's
just I guess reminding myself that that
I've done this before like I've done
tons of interviews at some times of
speed gain I've done all of this stuff
before if you haven't then remind
yourself of what you've done like the
steps along the way right my first radio
show is so nervous for but I've done
other interviews so like okay that's not
that big a step I can do this I have
confidence you will to do it um I think
enjoying yourself outside of your your
work your life you know I do salsa
dancing and djing 20 hours 8 ah you know
time with my family I you know play
league of legends um did this break from
from your normal kind of daily routine
perfect perfect so this next question
Evan you and I are going to take a step
in the time machine together and we're
gonna go back in time okay what is one
piece of advice you would give to a
younger you um my one piece of advice
would be to believe um the hardest day
of my life was when I I was arguing with
my business partner we had this company
was making no money I turned down
six-figure jobs to do this business and
I'm making three hundred dollars a month
and I'm embarrassed to my friends invite
me out to go for beer and I have to pick
one thing a month to go do because
that's all I can afford where I'm
telling them I am really busy you know I
got all this stuff happening because I'm
so I you know I'm living the
entrepreneurial dream right I'm the guy
turned down the jobs they wanted to do
my own thing and Here I am you know
eating beans for lunch and can't afford
to go up for drinkin beer um so that
takes its toll on you and and it did on
me and there was one day um
that I told my I was at some family
function and until my partner I quit
because it was just you know I'm done I
quit I can't do this yeah I i have 0
self worth like I put every I'm working
hard we're trying to do a good thing
we're not just trying to rip people off
everything I've done in the past where i
had effort into it i achieved some kind
of success and here i am just sucking
everywhere it's and and so I like i'm
done i got i want to feel like i'm a
valuable human being um and I told Mike
Witt and and then just cried for for
half an hour and you know my mom it was
family man my mom come up and put her
hand on my shoulder I didn't know what
she was saying I was just like tears
come out of my nose it's just like I
can't believe I quit on something
because that wasn't my personality and
anyway I mean the next day I don't know
what what happened I just went I just
want my tip back to the business and my
partner didn't give me a hard time about
it you know i just showed up at his
apartment worked out of his apartment
and and we just got back to work and but
i like I almost like I almost stuck with
I almost quit you know I almost I almost
gave up I didn't see any light I didn't
know what to do I was hopeless and and
that's you know that's a message to my
younger self it's also the message to
other entrepreneurs that's why I built
my business around this because so many
people go through that I'm sure even
when you were doing the podcast and
everything you're doing like there's
times of doubt where you think about
putting and you're not getting results
and you know in Italy portal not to want
to keep going so my message among
yourself is believe believe that is the
mantra of today with Evan Carmichael
believe so I know that we are starting
to get very very close to the time to
end this but you really touched on
something that I want to make sure that
I dig into just a little bit more and it
was the candor of what you said was the
the entrepreneurial dream right and kind
of holding onto this image of what that
entrepreneurial dream was and and real
projecting that to other individuals
knowing inside that things weren't quite
going how you wanted them to go just yet
so staying kind of in that same same
spirit can you take us to your biggest
failure um that was probably my my my
biggest failure was was a collection of
just just sucking at my company I felt
like I knew what I was doing uh I was in
university I felt like I got all the
answers and I've been reading all the
books and I followed all the advice i
was watching on the videos and reading
the magazines like I busting my ass to
get this thing going and and I just
nothing was happening like three hundred
dollars a month is can't live off of
that and that moment I felt like the
biggest failure in the world uh and i
think i could have been more open with
people i could have been more open with
my friends and say hey look i'm
struggling and i don't i can't come out
because i can't afford it and we could
have they could have done something at
their house instead of going out to a
bar right I don't know I felt I just
felt embarrassed like I turn down jobs
that they wanted that paid huge money
that would have me travel around the
world to do this and and I wasn't
getting results and I was too
embarrassed to tell anybody about it so
um so what was the one key takeaway from
that experience that drove you to
success um the thing that saved me was
modeling success I realized and down
this part that I'm not the first guy to
try to sell software's or a song before
and I looked at successful companies
like Microsoft and McAfee into it look
at how they got started 0 to 1 don't
care how Bill Gates makes another
billion dollars now look how do you make
his first million us I wanted to do that
in learning from those success stories
help me get out of my hole and and
become successful so that's a big part
of the message I teach as well as
modeling other people what
goal you have somebody's already done it
and you can copy that strategy to talk
to your business so modeling success and
before I let you go Evan I have got to
ask and I've got to end the show with
you as a leader inspiring leaders so
with that what what inspires you um
people doing great things inspire me
people doing big projects inspire me um
people who have ambition and who want to
want to change the world to want to do
something important that inspires me I'm
what does it inspire these people who
are okay with the status quo who are
lazy who don't have important goals I
don't care what your goal is you know
your goal is to build the business of
your goal is to be a professional
musician if your goal is to to be an
all-star code or at a company just want
something out of your life and want to
make your life important like want your
life to be meaningful because most
people look for the evenings and
weekends and they just go to work and
it's another day and they hate what
they're doing so that doesn't inspire me
the people who are out there chasing
their dream doing something big whatever
it is trying to make the best life that
came for themselves that's inspiring for
me try to make the best lives they can
for themselves so leaders head on over
to leaders inspire leaders calm for the
show notes and Evans contact information
the highest form of leadership is
inspiring other leaders so be inspiring
and stay inspired Evan thank you so much
for joining me and inspiring the leaders
of tomorrow no problem that was fun
maybe we'll do it again definitely
cheers